[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and I'm Ayanna waved and
this is your news for Monday March 26
first of all we got an announcement
about eight Spice Girls animated
superhero movie that is indeed happening
which I think makes perfect sense oh
yeah for their brand with girl power and
everything that goes along with that
it's gonna be crazy but I think it
completely makes sense something like
spice world would have worked if it
wasn't an animated genre when it worked
how dare you well you're right but yeah
it totally makes sense I think it's
gonna have kind of a like you said
earlier josie and the pussycats kind of
vibe maybe like some Totally Spies if
anyone remembers that TV show um and
right now it doesn't really have a
platform they just have all of the Spice
Girls signed on ready to go and to voice
the characters which i think is
obviously pretty imperative that you get
the actual Spice Girls as the voice
actresses why else do it why else would
you even try to do that so everyone's on
board and now they're just trying to
shop it to some suit studios and
hopefully someone's gonna pick it up
pretty soon they're hoping for a bigger
comic book themed studio to pick it up
they would like Marvel Studios or DC to
actually pick it up maybe even have some
possible tie-ins with comic books or
something like that which would be
pretty cool again Joe szema pussycats
has comic time yeah so I could totally
see that happening yeah also DC
superhero girls yeah you know I could
kind of see DC
for that I don't know the crossover we
might deserve maybe also this week we
got some casting news the lego movie -
the sequel so far untitled just added to
its cast Tiffany Haddish who's an
amazing comedian and in girl's trap if
you watch that she's hilarious and this
sounds like the perfect casting addition
to another hilarious film which we last
left off with DUPLO so I'm really
interested to see how we're going to
continue that's a storyline if you will
so will she be a character or will she
be a standard Lego I can't wait to find
out right
also the Men in Black spin-off added a
few new cast mates as well which you
might have seen them in Thor Ragnarok oh
it's just a Chris Hemsworth and Tessa
Thompson that sounds amazing it's gonna
be great
so many black wear suits Tessa Thompson
in a suits are you kidding me
need it it's gonna be amazing it's gonna
be me right I mean I didn't know I
needed that until we mention it and no
oh yes Lisa Thompson in in a men in
black suit and nice tailored suit Oh
heaven look amazing no people in black
yes not just men in black well it's
always been aliens
well it's aliens as well exactly they
they are also rumors that they're going
to add another to the Casper since
there's pairs though I don't know I
don't think that's going to be someone
added to the pair unless they've changed
things which is possible or it'll be a
more ensemble driven pair
yeah and that's what we've reported on
the best with this movie is that they
are really trying to focus on a more
ensemble cast which would make sense for
men in black it's a little organization
that's right why not focus on the
organization of the men in black well
they better get to cast in soon because
that movie is set to release on June
14th of 2019 yeah so next summer yeah
this week we got a couple of trailers as
well for some TV shows and movies first
of all I don't know about you guys but I
was a big fan of the anime foody Coody
and Adult Swim is bringing it back for a
second and third season which of course
is going to be bonkers and we got the
trailer for it and it was long it seemed
just as crazy and surrealist as the
original series was as anyone who's ever
seen a Gainax the show guy next show who
would know you know it's going to be
just crazy and it was a little confusing
as well because with this trailer they
had both seasons combined into one
trailer and it wasn't like separated out
like here's the first season or the
second season here's the third season it
was just here at all here it all is
mushed together although I was extremely
happy to hear that there is some new
material from the pillow is involved in
this and of course if you've seen the
original series you know what I'm
talking about
I love the pillows I had that soundtrack
I played it a million times I saw them
in concert it was great so to hear some
new stuff with from them to go along
with this TV series was just oh that
added little extra something that has
got me very excited about this and again
it's going to be two new seasons so the
first new season progressive is coming
out in June and then the second new
season alternative is coming out in
September and that's gonna be on Adult
Swim so Cartoon Network we also got a
another trailer for Deadpool - that's
right we got to see some cable action
some trusty cab driver and also some
Colossus Colossus crabs full of
alliteration and a little outlook into
the
yes it's a little derivative I loved
that line I don't know why you like hit
me so hard that I laughed for way longer
than I should have with that line in the
trailer there that's how long you should
have yeah negasonic looks amazing good
I'm very excited for the film the
costumes the jokes just the action
everything looks incredible and it seems
like they're very aware of the fact that
it's a sequel with their little lion at
the end like just stop it - you killed
it
yes oh I'm happy that they're like you
know taking that in and knowing that
they have to live up to the first one
yeah and man if anyone can do it yeah
we'll see and we can see that very soon
because it comes out May 18 we're gonna
believe it's coming up so fast also this
week we got a trailer for a mr. Rogers
documentary that's coming out titled
won't you be my neighbor and we watched
it and there was just so many feels
involved it seems like it is going to be
just a heart-wrenching wonderful
documentary and a look into the career
life and impact of mr. Rogers and it
seems to have a focus on some of the
more radical things that he did
especially considering the time period
when he was doing some of these things
and so it's definitely focusing on the
impact that he has had on generation's
other people and definitely playing off
of that I don't want to call it
nostalgia because it's not really
missing don't like we all feel like we
have a personal relationship with mr.
Rogers yes he wanted us all to know that
we are loved and we can't even talk
about it without feeling a little the
positive force I need
yeah so this is great timing yeah and to
even kind of gut punch us more
emotionally they dropped this trailer on
what would have been Fred Rogers 90th
birthday so that was another part of
this whole marketing that is really
working with understanding even the
material that it's working with and if
you didn't watch it a couple of weeks
ago PBS also had a documentary mr.
Rogers it's you I like and if you
haven't checked that out you should it
was another just really wonderful
documentary on the life of mr. Rogers
included some really special guests some
celebrities that they were able to talk
to and they also focused on some of the
issues that he was facing through
filming I'm sure you can catch that
again on PBS but if you can't just buy
it
yeah and support the public broadcasting
episode because mr. Rogers would have
wanted you to do that but for the movie
that we got the trailer for that's
coming out on June 8 so June 8th is
won't you be my neighbor and then go and
support PBS and buy it's you I like
that's right also wanted to give you
some news because perhaps we have some
movie enthusiasts in our mix I don't
know are you someone who likes to go to
the cinemas perhaps well yours truly is
in an animated feature called multiplex
10 I play Becky who is an employee of
this multiplex cinemas and it's really
funny has a lot of like film references
in it so if you're a film buff or just
enjoy animated features you should check
it out it's not too long of your time
and you can get it on Vimeo on demand
and there's also a couple of webisodes
that we've already made and there's more
on the way which Becky hasn't appeared
in quite yet but you should still go
watch them and support us which would be
super super cool it's also based on a
comic series that already existed so you
can check
as well otherwise you can let us know
anything else that we missed this week
in the comments or on social media
Heather where's that for you um you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash other roofs and you can find me on
Facebook as Ayanna Wade or everywhere
else as awesome Ayanna and in the
meantime we'll see you tomorrow on top 5
or right back here next week
same time stay in place can you uh can
you beam us up
[Music]
[Applause]
you